of the months of Rocky negotiations a
breakthrough the Colombian government
and the National Liberation Army
Colombia's largest remaining Rebel group
announcing a historic but temporary
bilateral ceasefire in the Cuban Capital
Habana
it's the most important agreement ever
reached with the notoriously
impenetrable Guerrilla organization and
the biggest success so far for president
Gustavo Petro's ambitious plans of what
he calls total peace in the country
so important in fact that Pedro himself
a former Rebel in his youth flew to
Havana to attend the ceremony
this partial agreements bring us to a
ceasefire something that has never
happened in this dialogue a ceasefire
that comes with a promise to bring an
end in May 2025. the decades-long war
between the eln and the Colombian state
it brings hopes of relief to communities
long affected by Colombia's internal
conflict some of which have seen little
benefits from the signing of a peace
deal with farc rebels in 2016.
the truce will go fully into effect on
August the 3rd and initially lasts for
six months the negotiating sides will
immediately start working on the
protocols for a verification mechanism
that will be led by the United Nations
the sides also announced an agreement on
how Civil Society organizations will
participate in the process and help
verify the truths
something the eln considers fundamental
for the success of the negotiations
this peace process has to be different
we want to see the changes the voice of
the eln will be the voice of society
these will not be agreements between the
government and the eln no they will be
agreements that Society will build one
with the participation of everyone
countless previous attempts at
negotiating a peace deal with the eln
have failed over the decades and
agreements reached with the
organization's Central Command have at
times been disregarded by the regional
commanders that operate independently
from the leadership
negotiations were last suspended in 2019
when the rebels set off a car bomb in a
police academy killing 21 Cadets before
restarting last August
recent incidents have repeatedly put the
talks at risk but there is no doubt that
the truce announcement is a major
victory for president Gustavo petro and
his plans for peace in the country John
Holman Al Jazeera